[Music]
[Applause]
film series is a huge franchise and the
original film is a classic you know
you're essentially like the arnold of
the film um what were your first
thoughts about taking on such an iconic
film literally the first thing that dan
trackenberg said to me was like you're
the arnold schwarzenegger and that
concept i think i immediately was like
and then i like put it in a box and
never thought about it again
you guys that's crazy so no i think that
i definitely felt like when i originally
auditioned for this movie i did not know
that it was predator movie so that
wasn't a concept that was introduced to
me until later and i would often forget
that and i think that really helped me
because that's not what you know
nadu was going through either she wasn't
thinking like this is about the predator
it was just she had so much she was
going through so
every so often it would like the thought
would come into my mind and then it was
like too much to wrap my head around and
it would immediately leave but now it's
exciting to look at and go like wow we i
think added something in my opinion
valuable to this franchise and i'm
really proud of it no i completely agree
that you did add something valuable
because i feel like it's a unique
addition to the film series you know
it's that way back in the past and it
sheds light on you know the indigenous
community a group of people that have
long not been represented in mainstream
media so how important was it for you to
be able to bring that to the screen that
to me is my favorite
part of this movie that we get to talk
about because there's just so many
elements to it having i think in a
period piece like native people be
represented like this which is is so
unusual like i can't think of many other
or any other
uh period pieces where you see native
people have fully fleshed out
personalities or you know dynamics
between like social dynamics or anything
like that and in our movie like you have
those things you have different
personalities you have human desires and
things that you can relate to and and
i'm really proud of that i'm proud of
you too uh so pray really took the
horror gore and action scenes to like a
new level so what was the hardest to
film and which one was the most exciting
one to shoot goodness the scariest was
probably the river sequence because that
was a real
that was a real river we were like in
the mountains we like drove to a place
climb like i'm not even kidding like
hike down a hill and then took a boat
across the river to get to another place
where then they had built the dam
in the real river and that was where we
were shooting and the river was arctic
like glacial runoff water from the
mountains in canada even though it was
summertime the water was not warm so
that was like i'm very i love water but
i'm also like very scared of it at the
same time like i just i'm not scared of
it but i just have like a very healthy
respect for it so i'm like oh this is
really scary um so that was scary but
also i mean like so fun to see the
finished product and then obviously like
the end sequence fight was
very like
daunting
in the hopes of that it was exciting and
big and all the things you know
that does sound super intense um but
unfortunately that's all i have for you
today thank you so much had such a good
time yeah nice talking to you
you